based on a recent report there are more
people developing autoimmune diseases
than people getting cancer and heart
attacks combined it's a huge problem
with the solution giving you a lot of
side effects as in prednisone so they're
really at this moment is not a good
medical solution but I'm going to reveal
the absolute best treatment for all
autoimmune diseases and if you've never
seen this treatment boy you need to know
about it because it can greatly improve
your life and the cool thing about it is
it has virtually no
side effects as compared to the
treatment for autoimmune diseases there
are massive side effects okay it's just
terrible because over time you develop a
resistance to it it ends up not working
and now what do you do it's a situation
number two everyone can completely
afford this treatment okay it's very
inexpensive so that's some good news
number three and this is huge it can
actually reverse the immune attack I
mean think about what an autoimmune
disease is it's your own immune system
that's attacking your own tissues I mean
that's crazy so this treatment can
actually reverse that situation number
four it's scientifically proven to
reduce the severity of your symptoms and
I'm mainly talking about inflammation as
the big one how can your thyroid gland
or your spleen or your tissues ever
function when there's constant
inflammation going on in fact it
increases the risk of getting insulin
resistance it increases your risk of
getting cancer it puts you in a
condition where you have to constantly
take something for it like medication
which then have other side effects so
there's some hardcore data that shows
that it can decrease
interleukin-17 T cells now what is that
that is something as a part of your
immune system that causes
inflammation and this treatment I'm
going to show you will lower that okay
so your inflammation will go down this
treatment even has the ability to
reprogram your immune cells so it's not
just about giving you some symptomatic
relief it's about reprogramming your
entire immune system which is very
exciting number five it can increase
hemopoetic stem cells now what is
hemopoetic mean well this relates to the
bone marrow and the blood in your bone
marrow that is making what's called stem
cells which is really these undefined
basic cells that have the ability to
turn into whatever cells that you need
so we have the stem cell Reserve that's
very very important in the reparative
action and people even get stem cell
therapy right now for all sorts of
conditions and diseases and it's an
incredible therapy but this treatment
I'm going to reveal to you will increase
your body's ability to make stem cells
so you can basically repair in rebuild
your immune system and so the solution
has to be an improvement in
strengthening of the immune system
versus the current treatment which is
just the suppression of your immune
system which does not repair it and
number six this treatment is going to
decrease the need for medications number
seven which kind of relates to some of
the other ones it will give you a potent
immune controlling effect especially for
rheumatoid arthritis
lupus MS all sorts of skin autoimmune
conditions like psoriasis and then you
have the autoimmune conditions of your
thyroid like Graves disease or
Hashimoto's and then we have one for the
adrenals called Addison's disease so
it's going to greatly put control back
into your immune system number eight it
has the potential to increase the
quantity and diversity of your
microbiome and the microbiome is
basically 80 percent of your immune
system so that right there can be a huge
influence to help you as well and number
nine this treatment will give you
regenerative effects on your tissues but
in addition to all of this it can also
help you kill cancer cells which is a
nice little side benefit it can help
make you more intelligent it can improve
your cognitive function it can improve
your mood to bring you up it can help
also fix your metabolism
but other than that there's really no
other benefits okay
I'm being very sarcastic this is what it
is
fasting wow there you have it surprise
now what I thought was kind of funny in
some of the studies that I read
um they mentioned that wow you get these
great results when you're fasting but
then when you start eating you lose some
of these fasting benefits but what if
you just practiced routine regular
intermittent fasting okay well that
might work because the benefits for your
immune system actually can occur over a
period of hours of fasting I mean you
can get immune benefits from doing 18
hours of fasting but what I would
recommend if I were you and I had an
autoimmune disease is I would recommend
omad one meal a day on a regular basis
okay and have a huge meal that would
give you 23 hours of fasting which would
be huge okay now at the very minimum I
would do 20 hours of fasting and then
just a four hour eating window so let's
say your first male was at 12 noon and
then your second meal was at four okay
or your first meal was at two and your
second meal would be at six o'clock I
mean at the very minimum do this but if
you can do that that would be better and
do this on a regular basis that alone
will produce huge effects on your immune
system and number two interject regular
or routine prolonged fasting okay I'm
talking 48 to 120 hours that's fasting
for two days to five days on a regular
basis and I would recommend the 48 hour
fast every one to two weeks that is
something that's doable for most people
and it will give you huge effects on
your immune system if you're combining
both of these now depending on your
discipline and your severity of symptoms
you might want to add a five-day fast
once you get used to this okay once you
feel better maybe you do that once a
month but that would be huge in your
recovery the cool thing about fasting is
you lose your appetite so it makes it
very easy to do because
if you had to be starving all the time
and hungry and craving and doing this it
would be torture okay but that's why I'm
bringing up this next section right here
what I'm describing here is called a
Time restrictive eating okay you're
doing this regular routine fast where
you're not eating for a while and then
you're eating okay on a daily basis but
there's also different types of fasting
patterns like the alternative day
fasting which I don't recommend like you
fast one day but then you eat the next
day you fast one day but you eat the
next day the problem with that is you
never fully adapt to the state of
ketosis and so you are hungry constantly
and you're craving on the days of your
fasting that's like very difficult to do
and then you have the five and two diet
which is even worse where you're pretty
much eating what you want for five days
and then for two days you're fasting or
you're eating I think 500 calories which
you never really adapt and so I don't
like this either because it's difficult
to do because you you're going to still
have your Cravings you're still going to
be hungry
there's also calorie restriction which
you're kind of mimicking fasting by
reducing the calories to like 500
calories a day
um honestly I don't like that either
because it's not a true fast it's
mimicking your fasting and yes there's
benefits for sure okay there's
scientific data that states that it
works but again if you start eating a
little bit of food that alone is going
to stimulate hunger and you're going to
want to eat more it's not until you
completely just stop eating until your
body gets into a state where the hunger
just completely goes away so I'm going
to recommend time restrictive eating now
there's two very important videos to
watch next
one maybe you're already watched before
and that is on the underlying causes of
autoimmune diseases and I'm going to put
that down below but the other one would
be just on how to do fasting okay and I
put that up right here check it out